hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
there are some people in this world who
were gifted who excelled beyond the rest
their leaders visionaries and pioneers a
mystic all-knowing confidence surrounds
their image Bernie Madoff was one of
these people he was one of the best
traders on Wall Street
he was Wall Street his consistent
investment returns made him one of the
best fund managers in the world he
couldn't just invest with Madoff he had
to know someone be vouched for earn the
right to have your money accepted by him
Madoff served as the chairman of the
Nasdaq and revolutionized the trading
business he had spent decades building
his multibillion-dollar Empire until one
day the house of cards fell and when the
dust settled all that remained was a
decade of liars as sixty five billion
dollars he was the largest Ponzi scheme
the world had ever seen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Bernie Madoff would start his investment
firm in 1960 he started with $5,000 that
he'd made working during the summertime
as a lifeguard and another 50,000 from
his father-in-law in total about four
hundred eighty thousand dollars in
today's money in order to compete with
large investment firms Madoff turned to
technology his firm pioneered the use of
electronic trading opting away from the
historic human traders with this focus
on technology the company was able to
provide a lower cost for their services
which led them to have a substantial
share of market transactions while the
numbers are hard to find
it's believed at at one point five to
ten percent of trades in New York went
through the firm in 1971 the Nasdaq was
born
it came with a wave of new innovations
in electronic trading today the Nasdaq
is the second largest Stock Exchange in
the world
it's where companies like Microsoft
Apple Amazon Google and Facebook choose
to trade their shares Bernie Madoff
would go on to be the chairman of the
Nasdaq in the early 90s it was a very
highly respected position
but as Wall Street was caught up in the
mystic of Madoff no one knew that behind
the walls of Madoff Empire something
else was happening well almost no one
knew enter Harry Markopolos
he was a financial fraud investigator he
back in the 90s was working as a
portfolio manager at rampart Investment
Management in 1999 his firm had caught
wind that a hedge fund manager of one of
their partners was consistently
retaining a 1 to 2 percent profit per
month this turned out to be the work of
none other than Bernie Madoff Harry
Markopolos
was subsequently given the task of
replicating Madoff strategy at his own
firm rampart
as Harry began reverse engineering the
strategy he had no idea that he had just
stumbled across the biggest financial
scam Wall Street had ever seen according
to Harry it took him five minutes of
looking at made us revenue stream to
realize that things just didn't add up
Madoff's returns were too consistent
when the market went up Madoff made a
profit and when the market went down
Madoff still made a profit Harry
Markopolos was adamant that Madoff's
returns weren't real the return seemed
to be unfazed by the market conditions
there was little to no fluctuation
despite the market movements Harry had
two theories either Madoff was trading
on insider information or this was all a
giant Ponzi scheme a Ponzi scheme is a
pretty simple concept investors would
give Madoff their money to invest and
Madoff gives them a healthy return the
return doesn't come from actual
investments he simply gives back a small
portion of their initial investment and
calls that a return eventually the money
dries up so the stock needs to be
replenished Madoff then moves on to the
next investor and so the scam grows
larger on paper the investor has money
invested in Madoff's firm and gets a
good return in reality the money is
being siphoned into Madoff own accounts
as well as paying off old investors to
keep the lie afloat it almost seems too
ridiculous to believe how could this
have happened on such a scale under the
noses of some of the greatest financial
minds in the world but that was the
talent of Madoff he knew how to lie and
how to be convincing of it and besides
who would dare question the man who
helped build the modern Wall Street
as Harry began further deconstruct
Madoff strategy he immediately ran into
mathematical inconsistencies for example
he calculated that an order for Madoff
strategy to work he would have to abort
more options on the Chicago Board of
Options Exchange than actually existed
in addition he couldn't find a single
transaction by Madoff firms on the
exchange
Harry spoke with a dozen equity firms
but none of them had made any trades
that Madoff and this was strange
in reality Madoff hadn't made a single
trade since 1993 or perhaps even earlier
in 2000 Harry Markopolos took his
findings to the Securities and Exchange
Commission otherwise known as the SEC
but Harry didn't have any hard evidence
against Madoff it was just a theory and
some red flags therefore an
investigation wasn't opened but Harry
wasn't the only one who was suspicious
over madoff when asked about at several
years later he confirmed that hundreds
of people within Wall Street had been
suspicious but when asked why none of
them ever reported anything he responded
quote people in glass houses don't throw
stones by 2005 Marco Polo's had
uncovered many more red flags
surrounding Madoff and the SEC
eventually opened an investigation in
2006 but Madoff had ties with the SEC
and on occasion was even called to
provide advice Madoff also knew how to
get around the auditors testimony from
former staff describe how they cooled
down falsified documents in the fridge
so that auditors wouldn't notice that
there had been freshly printed the
investigation was closed eleven months
later due to a lack of evidence and soon
after madoff audaciously praised the SEC
same quote in today's regulatory
environment it's virtually impossible to
violate the rules many people couldn't
believe his crimes had gone undetected
for so long and that astonishment it
turned to anger when it was revealed
that one man uncovered the Ponzi scheme
even went to the Securities and Exchange
Commission five times to try and expose
it he was stealing my clients and I
wasn't going to tolerate that if you
steal from a Greek we come after
the stakes were so high that he bought a
gun and routinely would check his car
for bombs I realized then that Bernie
was stealing from the Russians from the
Colombians and if he was doing that that
was a very dangerous game for him to
play because if they found it they were
gonna kill him
but Madoff at this time must have known
that it was only a matter of time before
the hypocrisy in his words would be
revealed ironically in the end it wasn't
anything that the SEC or Harry
Markopolos did that caught Madoff out
greater forces came into play it was
December 2008 and Wall Street was
illuminated in red so almost everything
there completely wiped out in the Nasdaq
everything and more has been completely
wiped out the Dow traders are standing
there watching in amazement I don't
blame them 676 points down waiters here
working the phones say a lot of their
customers are freaked out waiting to see
how low will go they'll you're seeing
just broad-based declines across all of
the major technology sectors Apple's
under pressure trillions of dollars was
wiped out from the stock market as
subprime mortgages in the u.s. tumbled
the global economy in rushes of panic
people were reining in their investments
and cutting their losses Madoff knew the
end was near he knew that would no new
money pumping his account and his
clients asked him for their original
investments back the scam would soon be
over
so Madoff pulled every string to get
some new cash Bernie had created the
firm madoff securities international a
subsidiary based in London he
suspiciously had no clients this
fraudulent firm transferred 164 million
years in November
billionaire carl shapiro invested 250
million dollars at the start of December
and Madoff received another 10 million
dollar investment a few days later
Bernie Madoff had seemingly asked the
whole of Wall Street for cash dishing
out a 19 page booklet detailing his new
investment scheme but it seemed that
thing was enough the withdrawals were
still more than madoff could bring it
investors wanted their money back and
now the simple fact was he didn't have
the money so finally madoff decided to
turn himself in he didn't try to run or
hide
he simply knew that it was the end the
game was over and 65 billion dollars was
gone and thousands of investors were
left to pick up the pieces madoff had
been running this scam in parallel to a
legitimate side business a business in
which his sons mark and Andrew worked he
told them that he planned to give out a
nearly 200 million dollar bonus to the
staff two months early despite the firm
hemorrhaging cash amidst the global
financial meltdown his sons argued
against it but Madoff had no choice but
to tell them exactly why it needed to be
done he told him about the Ponzi scheme
and that he was planning to turn himself
in at the end of the week after the
bonuses were handed out according to his
sons this was the first that they'd ever
heard about it
fearing that they'd become accomplices
in their father's crimes they called a
lawyer and turned their father in before
he distributed the bonuses and the
decision to determine well we knew we
knew right away that this was that that
was our only course of action Madoff was
later arrested at his home then released
on bail under house arrest as Bernie
Madoff and his wife Ruth sat at home on
Christmas Eve the reality of their world
falling apart sunk in the two childhood
sweethearts laid down in bed and
consumed a cocktail of prescription
medications on Christmas Day the couple
workup to realize that their attempt to
run away from their problems had failed
Bernie would now face life in prison
I don't know whose idea it was but we
decided to kill ourselves because it was
it was so horrendous what was happening
we had terrible phone calls hate mail
just beyond anything and I said I can't
I just can't go on anymore
I mailed them it was Christmas Eve I
added to the whole depression he took
pills and woke up the next in the end
madoff didn't fight he admitted his
crime he offered his remorse but offered
no excuses 65 billion dollars of
investments had been wiped out from
billionaire's holdings to everyday
people's pension funds across the u.s.
as if it wasn't bad enough that the
economy was in meltdown people had now
lost their savings to Madoff pleaded
guilty and within a few months were
sentenced to 150 years in prison
today he is simply known as inmate
number six 177 - zero five four at a
medium security prison in North Carolina
at age 81 he will live out the remainder
of his life there while in prison
both of madoff sons had passed away mark
committing suicide after the scandal and
Andrew died from cancer and as for his
wife Ruth she no longer speaks with him
Bernie is allowed a 15-minute phone call
each day but he doesn't use it because
in his own words he doesn't have anyone
to talk to
moral of the story don't let great get
the best of you it's really not worth it
why did he do it there's a word that's a
very simple word that I think we all
understand it's called greed and with
that that represent I'll look at Bernie
Madoff next week in the next episode of
cold fusion we'll be taking a look at
the we work disaster so make sure you
subscribe so you don't miss out on this
episode it's a really good one thanks
for watching if you did enjoy this video
and want to see more stuff from science
technology history and business feel
free to subscribe to cold fusion don't
forget to check out my podcast and
follow me on Instagram and Twitter
anyway this has been to gogo and you'll
be watching cold fusion and I'll catch
you again soon for the next video
cheers guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]